>> TRANS COLLEGE FORMER LEAH
THOMAS IS SPEAKING OUT ON
HER FIRST TV INTERVIEW NOW
SAYING SHE DIDN'T TRANSITION
GAIN A COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE
BUT NOW MANY ON THE LEFT ARE
TRYING TO CANCEL ANYONE THAT
DOESN'T AUTOMATICALLY HEAP
PRAISE ON LEAH THOMAS.
NOW, EVEN TENNIS LEGEND --
AND I MEAN LEGEND, MARTINA
NAVRATILOVA IS FACING
BLOWBACK AFTER THE 18-TIME
GRAND SLAM WINNER -- AN
AMAZING PLAYER -- TOLD THE
NEW YORKTIMES F I FACED THE
MALE EQUIVALENT OF LEAH IN
TENNIS, THAT'S BIOLOGY.
I WOULD HAVE HAD NO HOT AND
I WOULD HAVE BEEN LIVID.
HERE IS CAITLYN JENNER ALONG
WITH FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
TAMMY BRUCE.
GOOD TO SEE YOU BOTH.
I SAW YOUR COMMENTS,
CAITLYN.
YOU SAID -- YOU WERE RIGHT,
-- SHE FOLLOWED THE RULES AS
THEY WERE WRITTEN.
PROBLEM IS THE RULES AREN'T
FAIR, WHICH YOU ACKNOWLEDGED
ON THIS PROGRAM.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
>> IT CERTAINLY IS, THIS IS
NOT LEAH THOMAS' FAULT.
IT'S REALLY THE WOKE WORLD
THAT'S OUT THERE RIGHT NOW.
IT GAVE LEAH THOMAS THE
ABILITY TO TAKE AWAY MEDALS
FROM OTHER ATHLETES.
SHE PLAYED BY THE RULES BUT
MY BEEF HAS BEEN WITH THE
NCAA.
THE NCAA SHOULD BE OUT TO
PROTECT WOMEN'S SPORTS.
YOU KNOW, TRANSITIONING -- I
REALLY FEEL LIKE IT COMES
WITH RESPONSIBILITY AND
INTEGRITY.
AND I THINK IN THE "GOOD
MORNING AMERICA" SHOW THAT
SHE DID, I THINK THERE WAS A
LACK OF THAT.
IT WAS ALL ABOUT HER AND HER
HAPPINESS WHERE WHEN SHE WAS
A MALE SWIMMER A FEW YEARS
AGO, SHE WASN'T HAPPY AT
ALL.
NOW, SHE'S ALL OF A SUDDEN
HAPPY.
I AMEND TO HAPPINESS.
I'M GLAD SHE'S HAPPY, BUT
SHE DID IT AT THE INTENSE OF
THE OTHER FEMALE ATH-- AT
THE EXPENSE OF THE OTHER
FEMALE ATHLETES.
INDIVIDUAL HAPPINESS HERE IN
LEAH'S CASE CANNOT TAKE
PRIORITY OVER THE UNDENIABLE
BIOLOGICAL FACT THAT SHE'S
TRANS.
AND SHE'S GOT A MASSIVE
PHYSICAL ADVANTAGE OVER THE
OTHER ATHLETES.
I MEAN, YOU SEE HER ON THE
BLOCKS, YOU SEE THE GIRLS
STANDING NEXT TO HER, SHE'S
LOOKING UP TO HER -- SHE'S
VERY TALL.
THE GIRL IS GOING, I CAN'T
BEAT THAT.
I'M GOING FOR SECOND PLACE.
IT SHOULDN'T BE THAT WAY.
THE NCAA HAS TO PROTECT
WOMEN'S SPORTS.
>> NOW THEY WANT TO TAKE IT
TO THE OLYMPICS, TAMMY.
WHAT'S YOUR THOUGHTS THAT?
>> CLEARLY THE RULES DO HAVE
TO CHANGE.
CAITLYN IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THE RULES AREN'T WRITTEN
WITH THIS KIND OF SITUATION
IN MIND.
IT'S ABOUT THE WOKE SOCIETY
BUT WHENEVER THE RULES THAT
WE ALL LIVE UNDER SEEM TO BE
REALLY ABSURDLY RIDICULOUS T
DOES COME DOWN TO CHARACTER.
IT COMES DOWN TO THE NATURE
OF WHO WE ARE, ABOUT WHETHER
OR NOT WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF RULES THAT WERE
WRITTEN AND SET FOR
SOMETHING ENTIRELY DIFFERENT
WITHOUT CERTAIN
EXPECTATIONS.
AND THIS IS WHEN IT COMES
DOWN TO WHAT WE'VE BEEN
SEEING WITH LIA THOMAS.
I'VE BEEN SAYING THIS FOR
QUITE SOMETIME.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
TRANSGENDERRISM AT THIS
POINT.
IT IS ABOUT CHARACTER.
AND IT'S ABOUT SELFISHNESS.
IT'S ABOUT SELF-INDULGENCE.
IT'S ABOUT NARCISSISM.
CAITLYN WASN'T KIDDING WHEN
SHE WAS TALKING ABOUT
HAPPINESS.
LIA NOTED THAT WHEN SHE
COMPETED AGAINST MEN THAT
SHE WAS MISERABLE AND WHEN
SHE COMPETES AGAINST WOMEN,
SHE'S HAPPIER.
WELL, SHE'S WINNING MORE!
SHE DID NOT WIN LIKE THIS
AGAINST MEN.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
OLYMPICS, SEAN, THERE WOULD
BE NO REAL CHANCE TO EVEN
COMPETE AT ALL LET ALONE BE
ASSIGNED ONTO THE OLYMPIC
SWIMMING TEAM.
SO THIS IS A REMARKABLE
EXAMINATION ABOUT
SELF-INDULGENCE AND
MALIGNANT NARCISSISM WHEN IT
COMES TO WHAT YOU'RE WILLING
TO DO TO OTHERS IN ORDER TO
GET TO WHAT YOU WANT WHEN
IT'S INHERENTLY AND
COMPLETELY UNFAIR.
THIS IS WHAT THIS IS.
THE TRANSGENDER PEOPLE OUT
THERE -- CAITLYN VERY GOOD
EXAMPLE OF SOMEONE WHO
TRANSITIONED WHO'S GOT
CHARACTER -- THIS IS ABOUT
INDIVIDUAL ATTITUDE.
THIS IS ABOUT WHO WE ARE AS
PEOPLE.
NOT ABOUT THE TRANSGENDER
PEOPLE AT ALL.
>> THAT'S A GOOD POINT, YOU
KNOW, CAITLYN, WE TALKED
ABOUT THIS.
YOU DRIVE THE BALL
200 YARDS.
I'M NEVER PLAYING GOLF
AGAINST YOU.
>> BRING CASH!
A LOT OF IT!
>> BUT THE POINT IS YOU
WOULDN'T PLAY A SENIOR EVENT
BECAUSE YOU FEEL YOU HAVE
THAT ADVANTAGE.
WE HAVE ABOUT 30 SECONDS.
>> YEAH.
NO.
I DEFINITELY DO.
I'VE BEEN THROUGH THIS WHOLE
PROCESS.
IN FACT, I'M COMPLETELY
TRANSITIONED.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE CASE
IS IN LIA'S CASE BUT I'VE
BEEN ON HORMONES FOR A VERY
LONG TIME AND COULD HIT THE
BALL A LONG WAY.
THAT'S NOT A PROBLEM.
HERE IS A GOOD EXAMPLE.
WHAT IF THE NBA ADOPTED
RULES OF THE NCAA?
MICHAEL JORDAN AT HIS PRIME
ALL OF A SUDDEN DECIDES I'M
TRANS.
ONE YEAR ON HORMONE
REPLACEMENT THERAPY AND HE
COULD PLAY IN THE WNBA.
HOW DO YOU THINK THAT WOULD
WORK OUT?
>> Sean: I GOT TO ROLL BUT
I THINK -- I THINK IF I DO
PLAY, I'LL BRI